23 Stockwerke hoch ist die Falcon Heavy, die
leistungsstärkste Rakete der Welt.
Am Dienstag startete das Prestigeprojekt des
Privatunternehmens SpaceX erfolgreich vom
Weltraumbahnhof Cape Canaveral in Florida
zu einem Testflug.
An Bord: ein roter Tesla-Sportwagen.
Der Tesla- und SpaceX-Gründer Elon Musk sprach
von einem fast surrealen Moment.
"Das war sagenhaft.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so etwas Aufregendes
gesehen."
Musk hatte vor dem Testflug erklärt, er würde
es als Erfolg bezeichnen, wenn die Rakete
überhaupt in die Luft ginge.
Der Start ist ein wichtiger Meilenstein für
Musks Unternehmen.
SpaceX bemüht sich unter anderem um lukrative
Aufträge der US-Weltraumbehörde Nasa und des US-Militärs.
Die Falcon Heavy soll durch wiederverwendbare
Bauteile kostengünstiger sein als andere Raketen.
Ein kritischer Punkt war wenige Minuten nach
dem Abheben erreicht, als sich die beiden
Seitentriebwerke von der Rakete lösten und
wieder zum Weltraumbahnhof zurückehrten.
Die Falcon Heavy kann bis zu 70 Tonnen Fracht
in die Erdumlaufbahn bringen zu einem Preis
von 90 Millionen Dollar pro Start.
Sie ist damit doppelt so leistungsstark wie
die bislang größte Rakete bei einem Viertel der Kosten.
Auf ihrem Testflug soll die Falcon Heavy mit
ihrem Tesla an Bord die Sonne umrunden.